yes you read that title correctly if
you're looking to buy
any apple watch including the highest
end series 5
for 400 or the budget series 3 model
for 200 do not click that add to cart
button on amazon
because i'm extremely confident that
within one week
apple is going to announce the apple
watch series 6.
and from the looks of it this new watch
is going to be packing a ton
of new features and for all of you that
don't want the highest end apple watch
there are some pretty solid rumors that
apple is also releasing
a brand new budget version of the apple
watch at the same time
so what i'm gonna do in this video is go
through all the leaks and rumors
and explain exactly how apple is gonna
release this
why it totally makes sense and what else
we can expect to come
next week if this is the first time
you're hearing this rumor
you probably think i'm crazy because
apple basically always releases their
new apple watch models
alongside their new iphones at their
annual
september event but this year everything
is different
during apple's q2 earnings report tim
said that because of delays
related to the pandemic their iphones
are going to ship
a few weeks later than usual so imagine
you're in apple's shoes
and you know that your apple watch is
ready to go but your iphones
aren't ready well why not just release
the apple watch on time
and that's exactly what many leaks and
rumors are pointing to
so let's take a look at this apple
release timeline created by the very
accurate leaker
john prosser he claims that the apple
watch and a new ipad
will get released during the week
commencing on september 7th
which is monday next week and then he
also claims that the iphone 12 event
will actually happen during the week of
october 12th
next month so it might seem weird that
apple's iphone event is gonna happen in
october
but tim cook did say that iphones are
getting delayed
so let me explain my reasoning apple
usually also hosts an event at the end
of october for mac
and ipad pro related announcements but
due to the pandemic
it might be a good idea to consolidate
both the iphone
and the usual october event into one
event
since we expect this one to be online
only
like apple did for wwdc and having an
online only event
is a bit more complicated so it makes
sense to just have
one event and i'm already expecting them
to talk about their new apple silicon
max at that same event
which means that there is a ton of
products on the schedule so in my
opinion
it totally makes sense for apple to
release some of their planned products
early specifically next week so they can
spend more time talking about the iphone
12 and apple silicon max at the event
next month and getting back to those
leaks
john prosser isn't the only one
expecting a release next week comia
posted that the new apple watch will be
announced
on wednesday the 9th of september with
pre-orders starting on friday
and what makes it really interesting is
that john prosser later tweeted
that his sources are telling him that
something is happening on apple's
website
on tuesday the 8th not on the night and
then later
kamiya retweeted john's tweet saying
that pre-orders will begin on the 11th
or the 18th so here's what i think is
going to happen
apple is going to release multiple
products next week maybe something on
monday
something on tuesday and something on
wednesday
which might seem a bit weird but apple
has already done this in the past
on monday march 18 2019
they released the new ipad air and ipad
mini
and the next day they refreshed their
imacs
and then the day after that on wednesday
they also released new airpods
and that's exactly what i think is gonna
happen next week
and on one of those days probably
tuesday we should
see the announcement of the ipad air 4
which i already made a video on which
you guys loved
and then on wednesday i'm expecting the
apple watch series 6
just like kamiya leaked so that
basically just leaves monday
so what else could be popping up on the
apple website on that day
well calmia says that the brand new
airpods studio
over ear headphones will be announced on
apple's website
with shipments starting in september or
october
and when asked about it he confirmed
that it will be announced on the apple
website
and not at an event and another leaker i
apple times is saying that the airpods
studio will be coming on september 8th
because the 7th is actually a holiday so
the releases could be limited
to just tuesday and wednesday and to
make the new airpods studio even more
interesting
he tweeted that apple is working on
inductive wireless charging
for those headphones now apart from that
we could be seeing a new budget ipad
getting released as well
since john prosser says that he expects
both a 2020 ipad
and a 2020 ipad air so that's two ipads
potentially getting released
next week and it's not just him another
anonymous leaker
claims that apple will be releasing a
new low-cost ipad
with an a12 chip which has to be the
budget ipad now there are some people
speculating that we could be seeing
another homepod smart speaker being
released
but kamiya and others are now saying
that we shouldn't be expecting that
until march of 2021. so to wrap all of
that up
we should be seeing at least three new
apple products getting released
next week on apple's website and not
during an event
and just now john prosser again tweeted
out
that next week is gonna be very
interesting
however there are some people that are
disagreeing with john prosser
at least in terms of the apple watch
release date love to dream tweeted out
earlier this morning
that there will be no watch releasing
this month of course talking about the
apple watch 36
and then i apple times also tweeted that
according to mack atakara
apple will launch the series 6 at the
october event
instead of next week and then jon
prosser countered his tweet
again confirming that the apple watch
will be coming next week and at that
point
i apple times conceded and said he's
going with
john prosser's timeline so from the
looks of it
we can safely expect the apple watch
series 6 to be
announced next week on apple's website
now to make it even more interesting
multiple leakers are pointing to there
being not one but two apple watch models
being released
and they'll definitely be released at
the exact same time
on apple's website and according to mark
german and debbie wu
there will be a cheaper apple watch
replacing the series 3
dubbed the apple watch sc and just to
confirm that the series 3 will be
getting replaced
kamiya tweeted that it'll be unavailable
by the end of the year
so based on all of that you should
absolutely not be buying any apple watch
right now
and if you just did you should check if
you can still return it
because next week's apple watch series 6
is gonna pack
a lot of new features that i discussed
in my recent leaks and rumors video like
for example
apple just won a couple of patents for
apple watch features
including touch id blood oxygen
monitoring
and gesture and limb position detection
and of course
the same thing goes for anybody thinking
about buying an ipad
i would definitely wait until next week
to see what happens with the ipad air 4
and potentially the budget ipad and as a
little bonus to this video
kamiya claims that apple is working on a
magic keyboard
2 exclusively for the ipad pro
12.9 inch and when asked about why it's
for the 12.9 inch only
he says that there's a chance that apple
will actually stop
selling the 11 inch ipad pro with it
being replaced by the ipad air 4 in the
future
so prepare for that so there you guys go
that's why you should not
buy any apple watch right now and if
you're as excited as i am for next week
check out our apple product merch down
below like our mask or our hoodie
or t-shirt and definitely click the
circle above to subscribe
because we're going to be reviewing
every one of those apple products that's
getting released
next week thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next one